I thought that scientists understood how
explosions work now we're not going to
see big orange fireballs going up into
the sky I've done that before I filmed
with a pyrotechnician we added a load of
fuel to make the blast look like a
Hollywood explosion but that is not
realistic besides these days Hollywood
and scientists can simulate those sort
of effects near perfectly in a computer
I looked it up there are industry
standard ways of predicting blast waves
they are very accurate once you're about
half a meter away and there's clear air
in between which is good enough for most
people because let's face it if you're
five centimeters away from an explosion
you've probably got bigger problems but
it turns out that's big picture stuff
right at the start in the detonation in
the first few instances of an explosion
as all the energy is released that's
where the simulations break down and
solving that problem could save lives
this Bleak Old World War II Munitions
site is now a University test laboratory
and the research is close up so let's
see a test explosions are very difficult
to measure we need something that's
going to be rugged and strong enough to
survive an explosion but we also need
something that's sensitive enough to
measure things that are changing over
millimeter length scales and sub
microsecond time scales the rig that
we're going to be using today is called
mace which stands for mechanisms and
characterization of explosions it's a
bit of world leading kit where we can
directly measure much closer than
anybody worldwide can do gigapascal's
worth of pressures and that's a very
very complicated situation which we
can't necessarily model or predict
currently and we're going to use some
high-speed video cameras to film what's
going on as well
if you hit a metal bar the right way
it'll make a ringing sound basically a
musical note that ringing is made by the
bar itself vibrating as the force from
that initial hit bounces back and forth
within the metal and the pitch of that
note is really easy to measure you just
listen the work the researchers are
doing here is much more Technical and
much more precise but it's kind of the
same process it's based on Theory by a
British physicist called Bertram
Hopkinson uh 109 years ago and it's only
now that the technology is catching up
where we can affix very very small
strain gauges and we've got data
acquisition systems that can sample it
that require rates and required
frequencies The Strain gauge is a tiny
dot that we mount on the outside of our
Hopkins and pressure bars solid steel
one meter long four millimeter diameter
and we fix this strain gauge 40
millimeters from the loaded face of the
bar we sample at five million times per
second we're going to set the explosive
a little bit further away from the
surface so hopefully we can see that the
Fireball and the detonation products
start to expand that's going to set up a
blast wave that's going to propagate
through the bar as a stress wave so the
strain gauge records a change in voltage
if we can work out stress which we can
work out the pressure and the load on
the end of the bathroom and there's a
whacking great big steel plate that that
just acts as a shield and just deflects
everything away so the pressure bars
trap that pressure and send it downwards
and then the arrangement of the mace rig
that we're building towards is 37 of
these measurement locations but today
we've just got one uh just to just to
focus on what's happening right in the
most severe part so I asked the
researchers what's the use for this the
first answer was well for Science and
that's fair enough but there are
practical applications to start with if
this works building things that resist
explosions will become a lot easier and
cheaper in the 80s and the 90s the Big
Challenge was big truck bombs with with
tons of explosives nowadays these
explosive attacks are much more targeted
they tend to be smaller devices and as a
result they're located closer to the
thing that they want to damage so that's
why we've looked In This Very extreme
near field setting we're going to be
doing some tests today with 100 grams of
high explosive it's around about tennis
ball sized there are a lot of secondary
reactions that go on it takes a while to
develop at least on our time scales and
there are ongoing chemical reactions and
that offers up the really interesting
Prospect of can we do something that's
going to mitigate them or even turn them
off can we surround explosives in a
particular type of material to manage
those reactions bomb proof luggage
containers or storage containers on
transport that's a potential thing that
could be done with this research
if we can understand those first
instance of an explosion then maybe we
can help keep it under control after all
this munition site is built to do that
it was designed to contain anything that
goes wrong by Brute Force just using
huge amounts of Earth and concrete
bunkers so can that be done with less
materials and less cost we're about to
take just one step towards finding out
we've never been able to observe these
features before so we kind of don't know
what we don't know that's what the group
looks at uncovering what we don't know
about explosions yet
[Music]
all right what do we got so
this is filmed at about a quarter of a
million frames per second
okay
wow
you can see it bouncy back so so it hits
the hits the surface as it goes back up
see it reigniting all that hot gas is
getting churned back up and it's mixing
with the oxygen and that's given that
secondary kick that we see at these
sorts of scale distances it's
continually pushing the end of that bar
and it's it's sending that information
down because it's not one hit it's a
push that it feels like one hit it feels
like one hit exactly but you're
recording that so quickly that what
you're actually getting is a push yep
wow
wow cool isn't it